[Musique]
cette année la journée départementale
des personnes âgées s'est déroulé sur la
commune du tampon
un rendez vous incontournable pour plus
de 10000 gramoune venus profiter de
cette journée organisée par le
département
donc comme à chaque fois on retrouve
donc le village pays avec les
producteurs donc agricole qui viennent
donc présenter leurs produits et souvent
des producteurs que l'on retrouve lors
du marché pays des produits transformés
et un peu plus loin vous avez également
d'efforts à près de 180 club de 3e âge
avaient fait le déplacement pour
assister à la messe et aux festivités de
la journée
la démo d'aliens accident et là ça va
pas le cadeau avec avec le club et
pouvoir unique et mange aussi pour
acheter de fait quoi mais vous avez fait
un vrai pic nic
on essaie d'être plus près d'eux parce
qu'il ya tous les renseignements tous
les les
et administratifs du département sont là
si les gramounes ont besoin de
renseignements chaque stand est à leur
disposition
nous faisons tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est en notre pouvoir pour leur faire
plaisir on démarre par la messe ensuite
il ya le bal la poussière cet après midi
et donc c'est grammont peuvent avoir
tous les renseignements qu'ils veulent
aujourd'hui sur ce site
le président du département a félicité
deux centenaires présents ce jour là il
a également remis le prix départemental
du mérite à jouer halberg pour son
engagement auprès de nos seniors
dimanche
on demande la troisième jeunesse de nuit
à danser avec nous aujourd'hui j'étais
dans le coup aussi pour l'organisation
de cette journée
vous voyez le public d'après j'ai connu
la n'a dépassé les 150 bus aujourd'hui
chapeau et bien sûr dans tous les autres
rassemblements
on n'oublie jamais la troisième jeunesse
est ma passion est situé période on a
essayé de continuer encore quelques
années et a besoin de donner de l'amour
ici à la réunion et nous donnons de
l'amour à nos gramounes par solidarité
mais aussi à la commune du tampon à tous
les bénévoles à toutes les personnes qui
ont participé à cette belle journée et à
tous nos gramounes ben ami jason bonne
santé amusez vous bien
soyez heureux une journée de fête qu'on
apprécie dans la bonne humeur et autour
d'un bon cari
[Musique]